well thanks for coming this is as you
know Gary Vaynerchuk
[Music]
I'll explain Siebel up in the car we
picked up from the airport this morning
but young founder school is a global
high school boot camp for high school
students to become entrepreneurs so
alright half the people here have been
through a two-day boot camp which is
pretty rigorous eight hours lectures
breakout sessions where they eventually
pitch real VCS it was basically Planet
of the apps before you guys decided to
come up with the idea yes I understand
and the other half have basically taken
a hundred Hong Kong dollars and try to
make as much money as possible this was
inspired by you by your eBay challenge
and some of them were in Cronulla like
we have team fidgets Pune so actually
one over here they basically finished
spinners always win so they just before
slime oh sorry so tell money tell your
story how much do you make with 100 on
con dollars six hundred you me six extra
buddy in an hour basically in one hour
you base the succession money because
how so you bottom where okay whatever
yep and where'd you sell them
at school even better I love it so so
they've all emails more questions this
story of my life okay the most questions
these are everyone here and budding
entrepreneurs they asked me a lot of
questions so we're gonna go one by one
so Kevin what do you ask your question
hey Kevin
so I I'm old I'm 41 so I was born in
Russia in the USSR and moved to America
when I was little and I was a kid
growing up in the 1980s in America where
entrepreneurship had no place from youth
and I'm sure a lot of you guys can
associate with this depending on your
parents nope my entrepreneurial journey
started when I was five six years old i
only as a kid wanted to make money as
play liked to me in the summer it was
more fun to go knock on people's doors
and wash their cars for five dollars
than it was to do anything else so i was
a really a pure what I would call a
purebred entrepreneur nobody taught me
it nobody showed me it I didn't read
about it it wasn't cool it's where my
life gravitated probably similar I think
I grew up more like an athlete or a
singer it like it pulled me in instead
of me thinking about it the biggest
difficulty I faced was because it was
that era
I was getting bad grades and making a
lot of money and everybody thought I was
a loser so my journey began from birth
and the most difficult part was my
entire childhood literally from fourth
grade until the senior of high school
those eight years I had to be within my
own mind that I was going to be
successful because every teacher and
every friend's parent told me I wasn't
gonna be and it was not that easy right
I'm sure for a lot of you whatever you
want to do that society your teachers or
your parents don't want you to do it's
not easy at this age to navigate through
that journey you know so my whole
childhood
yeah so I was wondering what was the
original mission for creating the wine
library and how did that mission change
over time so we were an immigrant family
my dad got a job as a stock boy in a
liquor store and it and you know saved
every dollar for 10 years to buy his own
store so my original plan and really
basically I delivered on it was I was so
grateful and so thankful for my parents
sacrifice of coming from a different
country and building a life for us that
I felt that I was talented you know I
had a very big feeling that I was good
at business so I wanted to go into the
family business
and make it much bigger so that I could
pay back my family so my original vision
was my dad's store was called shoppers
discount liquors it was very much a beer
and liquor store but we were in a
neighborhood that had some wealth and I
noticed people were interested in wine
so my initial mission was to just build
the best wine store in America like have
the best wines have the best prices no
the most one of the biggest reasons I
was a bad student was I would sit in
class and study wine while I was in
science class or math class so I was
very committed and you know I I really
my only objective was to build it so big
that it would pay back my parents for
the big thing they did for me absolutely
I think you know I think a lot of times
people take shots at me because my dad
had a business I don't think people
realize that I own zero percent of Wine
Library that my dad owns the entire
business that I built that businesses
growth and that I left that business at
32 years old with no income and no
collateral to build anything on so I
think that's a massively selfless thing
to do in your 20s to give up a decade of
your best years where you basically
leave with nothing you know a lot of
people just don't know my true story
that way so I think I achieved that I
built a business that was doing four
million dollars a year to a business
that was doing 45 to 60 million dollars
a year and I
that for all the value for my parents to
have so absolutely
I'm sorry Natan one more time
the entrepreneur and the idea that's
actually not the joke I call it jockey
and the horse I think about it like a
race and you know I think about the
business as the horse and I think as the
CEO as the jockey
I always if it's 50/50 lean towards the
person because some of the biggest
business Nintendo started as a playing
card company and it was the
entrepreneurs that ran that business
that kept changing the business you know
when I started vaynermedia I didn't
think it would be what it is today I
never thought it would be what it is
today I thought it was gonna be
something different so great
entrepreneurship is not being romantic
about what you started out to do
it's about adjusting to the reality of
what your business has to do and so I
never have invested that's not true
there have been times that I've become
so infatuated with the person that I met
that I invested even though I didn't
believe in their idea because I wanted
to build a relationship with them and I
thought to myself even if I lose this
twenty five or fifty thousand dollars in
the second or third business that she or
he builds she'll be successful and I'll
be there to be a part of it but far more
often I have to believe in your idea and
believe that you have the stomach
my biggest fear with your generation of
entrepreneurship is that
entrepreneurship is now cool and that
you're doing it because of either money
or coolness not because you can't
breathe without it and I'm looking for
entrepreneurs that can't breathe and
ever if you if you think in your mind
right now it'll be really cool to try a
business but if it doesn't work I'll go
into banking I don't want to invest in
you for me not that that is good or bad
that's just how I see it do you think
entrepreneurships in your DNA how many
think that this is what you want to do
for the rest of that
yeah by the way there's nothing wrong
with entrepreneurial tendencies right
like for example for more than half of
you did not raise your hand what you'll
learn in winning or losing in
entrepreneurship will make you a better
executive you know so I don't think
there's I don't think it's but if you
asked me think about it if 70% of you
didn't raise your hand
including let's make pretend two or
three of you would have but you're just
shy
so if half of you actually don't think
it's your full DNA if I put $100,000
into your business and you lose and you
say to yourself well I learned and now I
go on to do things that's good for you
it's terrible for me but I guess what
makes you invest in somebody else's
company when you could take that dollar
and invest in your own company
diversification because I can't I'm just
you can't you know look at all the money
I made in Facebook and then and Twitter
and snapchat and uber like I made a lot
of money like cuz I cuz I'm very good at
consumer behavior so I have three
pillars one I've made a lot of money on
Amazon and Netflix as public companies
cuz I understood they would work too
I've made a lot of money and other
investments in companies that work and
then I've built my own company so
there's three pillars for me the public
markets the private markets and my own
behavior and for scale and the ambition
that I have I need all three at least
the way I work because the other thing
you get when you invest as you learn you
know I get to learn by watching other
entrepreneurs navigate their business
and so I think it's valuable but I think
there's a lot of people you know my
friend Travis who's the CEO of uber
until very recently when he you know I
used to do a lot of angel investing with
him and then he became the CEO of uber
and then I kept emailing him like hey
did you see this deal hey did you see
this deal and he would say I'm only
focused on uber I'm only focused on uber
so for him and you know it's funny right
now I'm doing far less investing cuz I'm
very focused on the Vayner machine that
I'm building so it ebbs and flows one
thing that you'll learn
you're so young right now you guys are
so young right now
you don't realize you know how the hell
is everybody here 14 15 16 12 to 17 so
one thing that will blow your mind is
that I sit here right now with you at 41
years old and I feel like I'm just like
you I remember how I felt at 14 and it
feels exactly the same way I feel 41 you
can't imagine how much fire and passion
and how young you feel at 41 like when I
was 14 15 16 17 40 once even like dead I
get it it wasn't that long ago right
when you get to 41 and you realize you
feel exactly the same way you feel right
now then you start betting on patience
and I think patience is a very important
part of this game I mean I think a lot
of young people make decisions that are
detrimental in the long term because
they want instant gratification because
they don't realize how long life is my
number one favorite entrepreneurs Evan
Williams he started blogger which is one
of the first blogging platforms then he
started a company called oh do around
podcasting he shut it down as soon as
the Apple started the podcasting
platform and then he co-founded a
company called Twitter and then he
started a company called medium and I
think he's the best thumb I'm infatuated
with Evan Williams I think he
understands consumer I think Mark
Zuckerberg is the ultimate because he
built such a big custom company and then
he also understood consumer don't forget
not only did Mark build Facebook but he
bought whatsapp Instagram and tried to
buy snapchat three years ago for three
billion dollars so he understands
attention if the kids wants to pitch you
for their
it's one of the few things that you look
for you said you'd better the jockey
maybe a second years idea but if there's
a few tips you give them what things
driving you to the next in in real life
for their situation right now yeah I
mean right now I would say to you are
you willing to quit school right like so
right and I get it because you're good
that's right cuz you guys are very young
like there's a lot of people in college
and university that don't quit school
because of their parents or society so
if anybody raised their hand right now I
would have been very surprised that I
would have poked so I'm glad nobody
raised their hand so for me that becomes
a non interesting conversation I would
not invest in anybody's company here
because to build an actual company you
have to give it everything you've got
you have in you would have a side
project now if if I sat down one by one
and heard your business and why and how
is it conceivable that somebody would
say something so profound and so
insightful at such a young age that
maybe I would invest now just to invest
when they do it for real in five years
probably but you'd have to say something
really [ __ ] ridiculous
you know something incredible because
there's because your life's gonna change
so you know the one thing that is
different about 14 and 41 is you're
going through so many fundamental
changes of who you are as a person and
the course of your life at this age that
there's too much risk in all the
variable things that are happening in
your life not to mention that I'm not a
big fan of the macroeconomic climate and
think that we need a meltdown again and
so I feel like your your your age group
is very interesting to me because I'm
hope this is a very funny statement I'm
hopeful for you that there's a big
economic meltdown over the next three
four five six years so that when you
guys come into the game it's not gonna
be as easy it's gonna be a little bit
harder and that's gonna flush out
everybody in here who's a real
entrepreneur who wants to do it or who
wants to go to university and work at a
bank come on I keep reading
Jessica
so Jessica I don't I don't I've never
had a macro failure I've never I've
never man immigrant that came from very
little I've never put myself in a
position to lose it all you know I had
very big success as a kid selling I
could have I could have built a million
dollar a year seventy percent margin
business selling my fidgets of the day
which would have been baseball cards
comic books bobbleheads should I found
at garage sales like that was there for
me especially because eBay came along so
I would have cruised but on the flip
side I feel every day like the amount of
things that I make decisions on that
don't work out are every day I think one
of the great ways to tell the difference
between a winning entrepreneur and a
losing entrepreneur is how much they
enjoy losing so I love losing I love
being wrong
because I don't give a [ __ ] what you
think I don't care what my mom thinks I
don't care what TechCrunch thinks I
don't care what the Wall Street Journal
thinks I don't care about my kids think
I don't care what anybody thinks about
what I do on the playing field of
entrepreneurship as a man I care about
what my mom and daughter think but as a
business man I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks and the quicker you can
go to that place the more likely you are
to succeed because then you're taking
the proper risks and navigating your
business properly and I think most
people are not successful in business
because they genuinely care what other
people think of them
[Music]
what do I think the biggest trend is for
what next decade I'm extremely
passionate about voice so podcast and
Alexa Google home Apple pod like just
voice because I think the biggest
businesses buy and sell time I think the
reason you know all these infrastructure
companies that we have in Asia in the US
ubers and things of that nature anything
that saves us time right you guys want
everything right now all these fast
right now always anything that slow [ __ ]
like slow internet is like devastating
right like not not watching what you
want to see when you want to see like I
grew up where I had a wait to watch my
favorite TV show that's inconceivable to
you you watch everything you want when
you want it how you want it where you
want it so speed we've become addicted
to speed so I think voice is speed I
think listening to something in the
first five minutes when you wake up and
getting out of bed and getting ready is
information that you're consuming that
you're not looking at your phone because
you're in the shower because you're
brushing your teeth because you're
running somewhere so podcasts and Alexa
skills not to mention one in every five
google searches is voice because it's
faster anything that's faster is
something I'm interested in I don't
think we as entrepreneurs and business
people and the world have fully squeezed
all the value out of sound and so I'm
very bullish on sound
if you could go back in time and do
anything to sleep would you change
anything
I mean look I think anybody who's happy
is crazy to say they would do something
different because you never know what
would have happened you might have get
hit by a bus if you did something
different so I would definitely not
change anything because I'm very happy
that being said I'll tell you what I'm
doing well now that I learned from what
I wish I did differently I was there
when Google AdWords came out Google ads
and I started running them for my dad's
liquor store and they worked and they
really worked but I was still spending
money on direct mail on radio on
newspaper advertising I was doing
everything but the Google ads were doing
so well I wasn't smart enough to realize
I should have taken all the money and
just put it on Google now the reason I'm
doing so much Instagram influencers so
much Facebook Ads is because I know it's
a very good deal and I'm putting it all
on that when you have it's like poker
I'm not a poker player but if you're a
really good poker player and you know
that you have the best hand you go
all-in and that's on think about
advertising and attention when you
figured something out you go all-in like
that what you did with that if you can
scale that to other schools and get
other people and give them a percentage
you can build a two million dollar
business overnight you could you could
if you went to every [ __ ] school God
gave somebody a percentage to be your
representative and just did it you could
it's there
you know it's crazy you think of it as a
one day $100 $600 flip if you take a
step back and go okay if I give 25% of
the profit to one kid in every school
like what is that compound to and with
digital advertising as you can imagine
with the Internet there's unlimited
scale
yeah
oh what's this thing I actually have a
question she rarely an you [ __ ] up
yeah oh yeah I'm just kind of fever at
home
she said she read an article about you
experimenting on yourself and she was
wondering what you could that was what I
was just talking about so I produce a
lot of content on Facebook Instagram
snapchat YouTube you know I have a
podcast I have an Alexis skill that just
came out I try everything on myself
first and then it goes to vaynermedia
and we help brands and then I do it for
other businesses that I own or operate
first because there's nobody stopping me
right when I'm testing on myself I can
get the real data versus when you have
clients they say no a lot Chris
I think the biggest weakness I have is
that I think I can do everything I'm too
optimistic I'm too confident I think I
can do everything so there was a lot of
businesses I started them in 2009 10 11
where I would have a partner and I
wasn't able to deliver to the
partnership because I had so much going
on and no matter how hard you work no
matter how fast you work you still only
have 24 hours and so the biggest thing
that I'm doing better today then I did a
decade ago is I'm saying no more often
and I'm still saying yes way too much
it's all will always be my weakness I
just believe in myself too much that I
can squeeze so much but it is absolutely
my weakness and I think I'm getting I
know I'm getting better and better and
better but it's still hard for me
because if I see an opportunity I want
to do it right pull your superpower and
it's usually the differentiation you you
hire for the things that you don't do
well just to not have a vulnerable flaw
but you hire for the thing that you're
best at to explode your growth
the students here will probably be
getting internships or jobs very soon
what are the things that you would
recommend they look for in potential
employment is it the person that you're
working for the brand is it the sector
like what is it in the initial stages I
think you have to be interested you know
I think the interest matters but I would
actually throw a curve ball I would say
the volume of people that work at the
company to create the widest net for you
to make relationships there is nothing
you're gonna learn at an internship that
is going to be that valuable to you in
the long term because the world's gonna
change too much by the time you do it
for real
the biggest value you will get an
internship is the people that you meet
relationships are the constant
information is becoming very very very
not valuable effort you have to provide
more value to somebody than they give to
you the best thing you can do at an
internship is to ask people what they
need for you to do with your limited
knowledge of the business self-awareness
and empathy humility and then and then
just trying to bring them the most
basically the way I live my life is how
do I guilt guilt everybody into having a
relationship with me like for example
this this this little setting we have
right now right I'm basically in the
back of my mind saying how do I give
such good information that in 17 years
from today one of you emails me or
whatever however we talk then and and
say hey I want to do something with you
and I've got a funny story do you
remember in 2017 when you went to Hong
Kong and time and sat in a circle with a
bunch of kids I was one of those kids
you said something that helped me a lot
and now I want to do this with you
that's basically how my entire life
works because that's the best way to
sell have it come to you
we took a breakfast a little bit about
what students are studying these days
and medicine on coding right so how many
of you here one to actually learn how to
call it be a computer science graduate
how many of you tend to do that okay
what are your thoughts I think we you
know what we talk so I think it's gonna
become a very commoditized skill and I
actually think it's not a good bet for
the financial returns of today for the
future now if you love coding more than
breathing the way I like buying and
selling stuff well then you should do
that but if you think you're gonna make
the same economics that a developer
makes today you will not because they
were the ones of a generation when
people weren't doing it that were right
about where the world went and so they
were more valuable now you have an
entire world that is learning how to
develop and so by supply and demand
curves it will become a commoditized
skill and so inevitably the price will
go down for development and that is not
even talking about the commoditization
of what technology can do and where
those skills go now if you tell me
that's fine Gary but I'm gonna develop
in a language that's gonna be the
framework for virtual reality or augment
you know you can start getting into
something and if you're the best coder
in the world you'll find your financial
freedom and you may not be developing
just because of the financial impacts
like I said with my first statement if
it's your art form or your expression
then good for you but I do think a lot
of kids and more importantly a lot of
parents think their kids will be
financially safe if they become coders
and I think that's a naive point of view
because you're not anticipating to where
the world is going I would
I would if I was if I was yeah I mean I
would I would hope that you were as
fortunate as I am that at this young of
the age you knew you're calling you know
that's the goal I had the greatest gift
even though I had to eat [ __ ] and
everybody made fun of me I knew that I
had already won because as a 12 13 year
old I knew who I was gonna be there was
nothing else I could think of there was
no debate
it was binary I was literally willing to
look Society in its face
and go like right at it because I knew
who I was I'm just wondering if somebody
in here actually knows what that is
but doesn't have the courage or the
luxury of the mother that I had that's
embracing that desire because of the
world their parents see and they want
for their children and it's so cliche
you know for immigrant parents for Asian
parents for Hong Kong parents to push
their kids towards what they think is
right versus what the kid thinks is
right I got very lucky I looked at the
world in its face I was confident but I
also had a mother that gave me the air
cover to get away with it
what are these your parents are saying
hey you should be a banker you should be
alive and they'll actually be
entrepreneurs how would you you're
twelve your self how I don't want to sit
here and talk about something that is
not fair to you it's a very difficult
situation like what are you gonna do
like just cuz I'm gonna tell you to go
tell your parents to go [ __ ] themselves
like like you know that's not good
that's only gonna work so like to me
that is something that I don't have the
audacity to give you advice around cuz
all of you have your own family
situations I don't know you here's what
I would say appeasing your parents is a
long-term vulnerability to your
relationship with your parents because
you will resent them that feels very
foreign right now but when you're 29
when you're 42 when you're 61 you're
what you think you're doing to make your
parents happy becomes the thing that
ultimately destroys your relationship
with your parents because you will
resent them you just will that's just
true and that's tried and true and you
and your parents like here you know what
I'll give you one piece of advice pay
very close attention to the relationship
your parents have with their parents and
then try to understand what happened
there
if your parents were forced to do
something and they don't have a healthy
relationship with your grandparents you
should pay attention if they weren't
like you've got to look at that that's a
very important insight that could maybe
show you a path or create a pillar of
conversation the one thing that has
always worked on parents when you fight
against them is when you use the example
of their relationship with their parents
against them that has always been the
one move that gives you a some opening
of a chance like I helped one friend
through that he basically said to his
dad dad you want to have the same
relationship that you have with your dad
and that gave him the opening to do this
thing
hustle
ah that's a really good point uh so I
think the most important word is hustle
because I think it's the one thing
that's the most controllable like
everybody here is only so smart
only so intuitive like there's only so
much you can push but putting in the
hard work is so controllable I would say
the second most important thing besides
hustle is self-awareness and I would
actually probably argue that I've become
more fond of self-awareness even more so
than hustle if you really know who you
are
you have a much better chance of being
successful because if you care about
yourself you're gonna put yourself in a
position to succeed and so I would I
would tell you more if you took anything
from our time together spend as much
time trying to figure out who you are
who you are for yourself within yourself
within yourself when you talk to
yourself not what people think you are
not what some people think you're good
at not what you wish you were the
biggest mistake that people make is they
wish they were something versus
realizing what they are santé
uh empathy empathy is my number one
favorite trait if you can feel for the
other person
you will then be less political and you
have the emotional strength to be the
bigger person and every day we have
friction with each other and the way you
can go faster is if you're the first
person to say I'm gonna be the bigger
person and let us move forward even
though I think I'm right I think I'm
right all the time right like I have I
have confidence I have a history of
success but the amount of times that I
am the bigger person and let my people
do things that I disagree with is always
because I win either way either they're
right and I've learned something or far
more often they're wrong and I get to
make fun of that
have I ever made a business decision
that messed up a relationship with
anyone um I'm sure I'm sure because a
lot of times you're making decisions
where there's collateral damage and you
don't realize it right but with the
people that I've most cared about no and
I think not taking any equity in Wine
Library me and AJ stop my brother and I
started a business I was already a very
successful businessman I had a lot of
equity in social media he was a kid
coming out of college and we were 50/50
partners when we didn't shouldn't had no
reason to me and so I have always left
money you know it's very similar to your
question I don't value money very much I
have enough I always have enough I
always had enough if I make thirty five
thousand a year that's enough because I
don't spend thirty six right so I've
always not valued money which has
allowed me to be in a place you know
money is usually the issue so because
money has not been at the forefront
I haven't burned you know I've run two
family successful family businesses
which are very hard family businesses
have a lot of emotion a lot of baggage
but I'm sure I'm sure my college friends
who I didn't take into the business
might have not like that right I'm sure
you know quaint answers that have worked
for me that I had to fire I'm sure
quietly don't like that you know and
there's a lot of lightweight
relationships where I didn't know the
person I hired them they worked for me
for three years it went well and then it
didn't go well and then I'm sure those
people you know you have to be willing
to go there my you know my big thing is
intent I've never ever done anything
with the intent of hurting somebody ever
and that makes me feel very happy about
life
today
if I was to build a new business today
so I probably build an ip-based business
and what I mean by that is intellectual
property like a cartoon like I'm
obsessed with like Star Wars and
transformers and Hello Kitty and
anything like once you own it you own it
and I think that's one of the most
honorable things in a world where all
these big companies like WeChat Tencent
and Amazon and like they're winning
right they've become the layer above the
internet itself we're about to live in
the Internet so who else can make big
business the people that own the IP got
it so I would literally try to acquire
or try to create original intellectual
property that I could monetize that
seems to me like a very big opportunity
okay so we have about five minutes left
but I want you to go fast any questions
well I know you're interested in what
yeah then deals and you so I'm ready
here in Asia so maybe we should start
like networks yeah what's the what's the
first app that you look at in the
morning Instagram
what's that let's just go around the
whole thing I should want all this let's
go back to you snapchat Instagram
whatsapp snapchat which messenger
facebook messenger Instagram snapchat
snapchat snapchat Facebook snapchat
email listen what's that
Gmail snapchat
what's up
place of a messenger d-roc okay
snapchat what's that which one
uh-huh I know yeah I understood Facebook
Twitter look
Bloomberg mines text message right yeah
message by my native text messaging okay
what uh let's now in Reverse and we'll
even do reverse what's what's the thing
that you feel and this is a little
harder so you guys have a better so you
can think for a minute what's the thing
that you think you've dropped off on the
most in the last year the thing that
maybe you spent a lot more time on a
year ago today but not as much as today
I would say all sorts of OTT I Netflix
and all that everything you're not
consuming content no I'm actually
consuming education interesting like
what Facebook
study that's my favorite that's the
babies like I love that YouTube just t
television sleep Facebook TV Facebook
YouTube reading YouTube gate playing
Facebook what's that
movies Raisa
what's down from a year ago you haven't
changed in one year
get out of here no just getting a bit
gaming and TV gaming YouTube
sleep Twitter Facebook snapchat proper
tune what's that
all right what about who what about
who's your favorite influencer and what
do they like talk about if you have one
nope
[Music]
okay your grandfather
it's awesome Michelle Obama and what do
you consumer on Instagram on what
platform on YouTube
your mom like in real life like they
weird
LeBron James on Instagram
nobody really who I love it
I love it you want Musk
yeah there's
all too
Oh 100% where do you consume him mainly
Twitter like where do you consume this
content YouTube rice
[Music]
that - got it
your hope you took our online roses
right that's fine I mean they took it a
different place I like it it's cool your
mom
love it
right
so I will sleep like
so talks a lot about how to die
and they like get the most out of the
song so every
I prefer simple and effective
sacrifice to help me
yeah it's doing well where yep
yep
[Music]
sure it's the best do you rock well I'm
you know not me but I quitting I love it
you're lucky the best
[Music]
yeah no they aren't it's awesome Gordon
Ramsay yeah nossek yes he is nobody mine
yeah
on what yeah very cool
Steve Jobs
was crazy
yeah for sure got advantage of course
okay guys well that's about all we got
time for you got now some channels to
call me selfies whatever you guys want
to do we're about 15 10 15 minutes we do
have to leave here at 12:00 on the dot
so do we need to do big thank you to
Gary thank you so much you're welcome
[Applause]
[Music]